vous devez payer votre loyer de 650
euros exact vous avez un crédit de 530
euros que j'étais obligé de faire pour
acheter une voiture pour faire le corail
Picard c'est ça voilà c'est ça
130 euros de crédit en plus pour le
couple pour travailler
parce que je fais j'ai pas le choix moi
j'ai fait le calcul 200 € de course par
mois oui encore je mange pas tous les
jours
de carburant oui 50 euros de forfait
internet et téléphone ce que ça on
compte on le compte maintenant ça c'est
on est obligé de le compter maintenant
tout le monde donc c'est c'est vrai
qu'avant c'était une défense que vous
aviez pas avant aujourd'hui c'est une
dépense que obligatoirement 40 euros
d'assurance de voiture 26 € d'assurance
habitation sans compter la mutuelle
l'assurance décès des frais de rejet
donc janine se retrouve tous les mois
avec 700 euros de découvert
je peux vous montrer
Jeannine on se connaît bien en plus tous
les deux chérie donc 700 euros de
découverte tous les mois et je suis
obligé de de tenir le contact avec ma
banquière quand je vois que je regarde
mes comptes et que je vois que ça
commence à aller un peu trop vers le
trop trop négatif je préviens ma
banquière je dis surtout essayer de
payer mes prélèvements parce que ton nom
je vais me taper encore 20 € des 80 € de
frais etc
alors j'ai commencé à 16 ans
je comprends pas la tête
nous parce que la dernière fois j'ai pas
être plus aller jusqu'au bout de ce que
je disais on est j'étais pour le pouvoir
d'achat j'ai parlé d'une tomate mais je
mangeais la tomate sur une tomate de
cœur de bœuf en 4 fois mais seulement je
mangeais avec un peu de salade un peu de
thon j'ai pas eu le temps de le dire
alors je vous dis pas comment j'étais il
y avait du temps mais arrête avec les
réseaux sociaux